>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Joan Weeks: Well, good
afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
On behalf of all my colleagues, and
in particular Dr. Mary-Jane Deeb,
Chief of the African and
Middle East Division,
I'd like to extend a very
warm welcome to everyone.
I'm Joan Weeks, Head of the Near
East Section, that is the sponsor
of today's program, along
with the Asian Division
and the Roshan Institute
for Persian Studies.
We are very pleased to continue
the Persian Book Lecture Series
with today's program on Persian
Manuscripts in India, Collections,
Curators, and their Future.
Before we start today's program
and introduce our speaker,
I'd like to just give you a
brief overview of our Division
and its resources in the
hopes that you'll come back
and use this Reading Room and the
Asian Division for your research.
First of all, there's cards,
you can get a Reader Registration
Card downstairs on the first floor,
and then come back up and search in
our catalogue at catalogue.loc.gov,
and search on terms; for example, if
you were interested in future study
on Persian Manuscripts, you could
do a key word subject search,
and you could refine
your search to India,
and a pull up Persian
Manuscripts in India,
and you can even limit by language.
So, you can retrieve materials
in the language of your choice.
In this Reading Room, we
cover Arabic, Persian,
2000 languages in over 78 countries.
This is a custodial division,
comprised of three sections
that build and serve the
collections for researchers,
and we have our Africa section that
covers all of Sub-Saharan Africa.
The Hebraic Section is
responsible for Hebraic worldwide,
and the New East Section covers
all of the Arab countries,
including North Africa, Turkey,
Turkic Central Asia, Iran,
Afghanistan, the Muslims from
Western China, Russia, the Balkans,
and the people of the caucuses.
I'd also like to invite you
to try our Four Corners Blog.
Here, our curators give you very
special glimpses of our collections
and very interesting articles.
And you can also hear and
receive alerts about our programs
on Facebook and using our RS Feeds.
So, this little flyer gives
you a wealth of information,
and if you subscribe, you'll be able
to get many more alerts
about future programs.
And I also would like to remind you
that this program is being recorded.
We invite you to ask questions
at the end, but if you do,
you're implicitly giving us
permission for you to be recorded.
So, now, I'd like to call upon
Jonathan Loar of the Asian Division
to give you a quick overview
of the Asian Division,
and then he'll introduce
further speakers.
Thank you.
>> Jonathan Loar: Hi everybody.
Many thanks to John and Hirad
and the rest of the African
and Middle Eastern Division,
as well as Matthew Miller
and the Russian Center,
the University of Maryland,
for helping to organize today's
lecture with Dr. Shekhar.
So, my name is Jonathan Loar,
and I'm the Asian Division's
South Asian Reference Librarian
and Recommending Officer for
India, Nepal, and Sri Lanka.
Before we get started, I just
want to give a little background
about the Asian Division,
which is one
of the co-sponsors
of today's lecture.
So, founded in 1928, the Asian
Division has custody of more
than 3.2 million physical items
in over 100 Asian languages.
The Asian Division has seven
distinct collections, Chinese,
Japanese, Korean, Tibetan,
Mongolian,
South Asian, and South East Asian.
This assemblage is one of the
world's largest collections
of Asian language materials
outside of Asia.
The gateway for researchers
and the general public
to use these collections is the
Asian Reading Room, which is located
in Room 150 of the Library's
Thomas Jefferson Building,
this building here.
Reference librarians are also
available in the Reading Room
to assist with any and
all research questions.
The South Asian collection
encompasses materials from Bhutan,
Bangladesh, India, the Maldives,
Nepal, Pakistan, and Sri Lanka.
Much of the Library's South
Asian acquisition comes
through two overseas offices, one
in New Delhi, which opened in 1962,
and the other in Islamabad,
which opened in 1965.
Currently, the South
Asian collection has more
than 300,000 monographed
volumes, more than 1,600 journals
with 67,000 issues for
active and inactive journals,
more than 18,000 reels of microfilm,
and more than 68,000
titles in microfiche.
These items are available in Urdu,
Hindi, Bengali, Tamil, Punjabi,
Gujarati, Sindhi, Nepali, Subscript,
Malayalam, Telugu, Canada,
and many other modern languages.
The South Asian collection, like
the other Asian collections,
also has a large and growing list of
electronic resources and databases.
Overall, this collection
provides broad research coverage
in most fields and disciplines,
particularly in the areas
of vernacular languages, literature,
religion, philosophy, history,
politics, and also
South Asian society.
It is also especially strong with
regard to newspapers, journals,
and government publications
from South Asia.
And without further ado, I'd
like to invite Fatemeh Keshavarz
of the University of Maryland
up to say a few words
ahead of today's lecture.
Thank you.
[ Audience Applause ]
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz:
Thank you very much.
I'm director of Roshan
Institute for Persian Studies
at the University of Maryland.
I'm delighted to let you know
that we do have a full program
in Persian Studies in which
students can major and minor
in the language studies, but
they also can take a wide range
of courses in various
areas of culture
and literature to enrich
their studies.
But I wanted to just
very briefly for a couple
of minutes tell you that,
but of course, as I came here
to start directing the Institute
five years ago, one of my goals was
to connect to as many
centers of learning and areas
in which we could actually come
out of the classroom and be
with the people who are interested
in what we have to offer.
And the first place and
the most exciting place
that I have found has been
the Library of Congress.
There's absolutely no other
place I can compare with this,
and I remember when we were
searching for a home in the area,
my one criteria was how close is
it to the Library of Congress.
And you know, as a monument really
to the significance of learning,
the Library has now taken a
bigger and more important step
of interaction with people because
you can store knowledge in the form
of books and manuscripts, but
there's a lot of difference
between that and bringing
it to the people.
So, this monument has been enlivened
with spirits of learning and work
and interaction and reaching out
to people like Mary-Jane Deeb,
like Hirad Dinavari, who will
speak to you, like my colleague,
director of the Middle
Eastern Studies, Joan,
who just spoke earlier,
and it really is a tremendous
pleasure for us to work together.
I'm not going to go through
the history of what we've done
because it will take too long, but
we will continue what we are doing
in days like this, and it is
really a tremendous pleasure
to be hosting Professor
Chander Shekhar,
who gave a beautiful talk
yesterday to a full room
of young Persian learners, who
were delighted to hear about India
and the role that that tremendous
culture has had in the development
of Persian, basically being a hub
for Persian culture and literature.
So, with that, I thank
you all for being here.
I look forward to many more
occasions such as this.
Thank you.
[ Audience Applause ]
>> Hirad Dinavari: Thank
you very much Dr. Keshavarz
for a wonderful talk.
That was very, very
generous and kind of you.
Also, I want to thank you for
making it possible for Dr. Shekhar
to come here from India, and
I'm glad that Roshan is working
with wonderful scholars
of his caliber.
Without taking too much time,
I'm going to read his
very distinguished bio.
It's a very long bio, so
please don't be offended
if I cut it a bit short.
Thank you very much.
First of all, and I must say
to everyone and [inaudible]
to all the Persian speakers,
thanks for being here.
Professor Chander Shekhar is
teaching in the Department
of Persian since September
1982 and New Delhi University.
He is a Ph.D., his Ph.D.
thesis on A Critical Analysis
of the Musnavis [phonetic]
of Anmi Husro, who was judged
as the second best thesis
by the Mojave Foundation,
Switzerland and was awarded in 1990.
He is a recipient of
the UTC Korea Award,
an award from the Iranian
President for Cultural Studies,
and the Saudi Award in 2010,
and the Favro Dean Ali Amat
Parlib [phonetic] Award
for Persian Studies in 2014.
For research support, he has been
awarded British Academy Award
in 2014 to 2016 to work on law forms
from the Shajahan [phonetic]
period until the 18th century.
He was invited to Sorbonne
University, Paris, and I'm not going
to read the Institute of
Languages, Sorbonne Studies,
for a series of lectures
in June and July of 2015.
He is a member of the
International Advisory Board
of Perso-Indica Project,
Sorbonne University,
Paris and Bonn University in Bonn.
He is being funded by
the EU Research Council.
He organized the third Perso-Indian
Conference in the University
of Delhi in September of 2015.
He is a member, a secretary
of Academy of Persian Language
and Literature of Iran, Tehran, for
the Encyclopedia of Persian Language
and Literature in the
subcontinent, a three-volume work.
He has published 22 books so far
on Textural Studies of English
and Indie Translations
of Indo-Persian text
and 42 papers published in
National and International Journals
and Encyclopedia, including
Encyclopedia Britannica.
Five of these have been published in
the National Mission of Manuscripts,
Ministry of Culture,
GOI in New Delhi.
His edited texts have been edited
by internationally known scholars
like Professor Carl Ernst, Columbia
University; Professor Fabrizio,
University of Soho in Paris; and
William Dalrymple in his works,
White Moguls and Last Moguls;
and also Professor
Robert Elgood of SOAS.
He is also a project in
charge and chief editor
of the multi-volume Lexicon
Farhangar a Yon [phonetic];
six-volumes have been
published so far.
It's a Persian English
Hindi and Urdu Lexicon.
This project is funded by
the Iranian government.
Recently, he has been selected as
the research guide and consultant
on a multi Universities of Europe,
South Asia, Central Asia project,
initiated by the Exeter University.
European Research Council has
approved the funding for this.
So, I can go on and on and on.
There's another -- you get the idea.
He is the expert, and I have to tell
you, as someone working with Persian
and with the wonderful
help of University Mellon
and other scholars, the
unique Persian that comes
out of the subcontinent, India
and Pakistan, is quite special
because it's Persian; yet,
it has a heavy terminology
of Indican sense great and
Hindu terms that Iranians
and Afghans don't get; and we
really need specialists like him
who can help us decipher what we
have in our collections from India.
And last, I can say
easily a third or not more
of the Persian rare treasures
here are from India, lithographs,
manuscripts, early imprints.
It was quite a bit of Persian that
was produced in India by Indians
for Indian audiences,
as well as for Iranian
and other Persian speaking
audiences.
Thank you, Dr. Shekhar.
>> Chander Shekhar: Thank you.
[ Audience Applause ]
>> Chander Shekhar:
I'm totally grateful
for that learned [inaudible]
officials of [inaudible]
and Middle Eastern Studies,
Library of Congress, especially Joan
and others, Mr. Hirad, and Professor
[inaudible] from Russian Foundation,
Mellon University, Dr. Matthew,
who have been instrumental
in making a contact between Delhi
University and Mellon University
of Library of Congress, and I hope
this initiative will bring more
and more folks to these initiatives.
In fact, I have come to learn
more, not to speak a lot.
I'm also fortunate that
truly I'm standing here due
to my former teacher [inaudible],
whose sister is working
at this Library, and I
guess [inaudible] here.
And I'm glad that whatever
I have learned I can pass
on to the next generation, and
that has been the foremost aim
of this presentation.
As every one of you might
be knowing in India,
Persian became old language.
I can stay that language of masses.
Old language, language of elites,
language of ad musician
[phonetic], right from 12th century.
They are mentioned that Arabic
has been the language of religion
and the partition of
reading scriptures
and for the monumental
[inaudible] scripture [inaudible].
It develops into [inaudible] that
the majority of the rules ruled
within 12th century until 19th
century, none of them was Iranian,
but Prussian language dominated.
The earliest people from
[inaudible] were basically
from the Neoclassicism idiom,
[inaudible] of their audits,
of the [inaudible] and the
source of the [inaudible].
They were all from this.
We can say that larger
subcontinent part, basically.
From 15th century until 19th,
the last word we say [inaudible]
modern empire completely ended
in 1857.
They were also not
Iranians, and they were also
from the minor central
[inaudible], basically.
But Persian remained as a
language of all of these.
And not only that [inaudible]
a huge call
for self-literature not only the
resources, scientific material,
all was scribed in this language.
If you read third volume of
British level Master of [inaudible],
you'll find that almost
4,000 manuscripts
in a single commissioned work
of Illiten Danson [phonetic],
who wrote History of India, a story
by [inaudible] procured and brought
to British Library, and these are
to the and [inaudible] of the same.
Apart from that, there
are many other collections
which have not been yet catalogued
like the [inaudible] Collection,
which they are now cataloguing
with [inaudible] Merusla [phonetic]
with the home art presentation they
sent in the School of Economics.
There are 137,000.
If you also look at the
catalogue of the Manuscripts
of the European libraries,
American libraries,
majority are highly illustrated and
illuminated masters [inaudible].
But still, their number may not
go beyond 20 to 35,000 maximum.
And recently until now, we have more
than 5 [inaudible]
Prussian manuscripts,
more than 60 [inaudible]
documents in Prussian and India,
and these are scattered
over in three categories;
one of the National Library that
has libraries of the Museums
and the Central Government
control, like National Museum,
the late [inaudible] Library,
[inaudible] National
Library [inaudible],
Solagen Museum [inaudible],
and many others like this.
Then, there are also
strict libraries,
which also have Prussian
manuscripts and documents.
Many of these have been
catalogued and many have not been
yet because still purchase of
the manuscripts is going on.
I remember being a member
of the Purchase Committee
in Lampur just four years back.
We had purchased about 160
manuscripts just in two days,
and we gave away about half a
million rupees, and this was,
that's what's going on, and
these are just in the shelves
of the libraries, not
catalogued yet.
So, my submission is that there is
a huge collection of manuscripts
in government, and there's
a part of collections
as Russian formation
has been successful
to persuade [inaudible]
act like no to catalogue
and destroys their
collection, which is almost at 8
to 10,000 manuscripts available.
There are many others.
In many concords there
are manuscripts.
There's many of that are
one particular [inaudible]
that we call [inaudible] them like
a leagus [phonetic] in the known
and a leagus set basically.
And these question that not only in
the Muslim collection I'm also had;
these are in many Hindu
Temples also,
you'll find the Persian manuscripts.
Documents in Persian, and just
scriptures, often those in Persian,
and differing manuscripts,
which are out in many American
and the [inaudible]
libraries from the same faith.
Also, from the Russians, Jews,
Christianity, a lot, a lot,
and still we are being out.
The question is what
we are doing with that
and what you people
are doing with that.
This presentation just as
an indicator to the variety
of the manuscripts we have in
Lampur [inaudible] or Salanga,
or some illegal [phonetic]
Muslim industry.
I also mentioned in many
industry [phonetic] libraries,
in my own [inaudible]
libraries we are
about 300 manuscripts
of Prussian alone.
Like as in Alibab industry,
[inaudible] industry,
a very good collection.
When we received these manuscripts,
we had to kind of information.
One is about the external
physical street.
Their script, their ears of
the period of the writings,
and which is also show that
evolution of that Persian and India
because with the Persian
script or the Arabic script,
many other scripts like
of Sundi and [inaudible],
they were also developed.
And how, even within
the Prussian script,
letters like [inaudible] they
are [inaudible] were developed,
and these master tell
us which are the period
in which this letter
became present form.
For again, example, the letter
Golf, for G, which is two strokes,
are you, many of you
know Prussian know.
Prior to 1830s, as
I was looking at one
of the manuscripts Hirad had
shown me, and when I remarked
and he went back to see
the year, and we found it.
It is from 1830s, prior to
that, we will not find that.
But in the early 18th century, the
letter P is done only with a book,
and this is one of the reasons
that only in any of [inaudible]
that it should be pronounced
like bifose [phonetic],
but in the [inaudible] and it should
be pronounced like [inaudible].
So, these masters also tell us
about the photographic information.
Then, we have illustrated
masterpiece of show,
which are not the imperial
or the regional old
manuscript illustrations.
These are from the
masses, and this tell us
about the society also
and in culture.
So, that idea when permission about
the art of book working especially,
that two [inaudible] manuscripts;
one, which was scribed in India,
and the other which
was from other world.
Like this, on one hand,
in the Art of Book Making,
there was a continuity of
decorating the books with a silver
and gold illuminations and a variety
of designs were created on these.
This is one of our master,
scribed in gold [inaudible] namely
[inaudible], all in Indian detail
of [inaudible] and it's a catalogue.
It's interesting.
It starts from the city of
Ogden and Ismahen [phonetic].
So, this is [inaudible] variety
of confluence of culture came up,
language came up, and
then as Hirad mentioned,
variety of the wonderful words not
only of Henry, Sastrick, Konert,
Filbu, Bungla,[phonetic] Panjabi,
and many of this also came up.
We know that paper was
not easily available
after 7th century [inaudible] and
counter the Chinese paper started
at summercom; then it went
to Aleppo, and from 11th
and 12th century onward, with
the direction of [inaudible],
the best paper for [inaudible]
was started producing in Kashmir.
But apart from that, there
were many other places
where paper was produced, and the
majority of the works which we found
in the treasure right
from [inaudible]
until even site we can
see that the majority
of the masters was
scribed in India itself.
On every manuscript from
the position of book,
we know that there are fly leafs,
and fly leafs are really
important in many ways.
And this was our suggestion
[inaudible] wanted that.
Then, we destroy the
manuscripts usually
with these ties only the
textual part, not the fly leaf,
but the fly leafs are very
important in omission.
About the pictures of the
book, itself the person
who brought first time
of the possession
of the programs it mentions,
it provided us the detail,
also some political, and
I will show you that,
so that manuscript is not only
the text but the fly leafs.
Some of the notes which
are mentioned and that
after that program
and [inaudible] also.
This is one of the
manuscript from Gulistan
of Raza Library Rampur scribed
by that a known calligrapher
Sofali Machevi [phonetic].
If you can see in the bottom,
it is clearly mentioned
his name and Vasili.
At the bottom of this corner,
you can see this is the writing
of a renowned collector, a renowned
noble of the Rahim Khan-e-Khanan,
and he had a moving library,
having around 5000 manuscripts
with a book atlier always the
gilders, paper cutters, scribes,
printers, all what
used to go with him.
He established his first
library at Endoval [phonetic],
second in Sanowich [phonetic],
third at Baronco [phonetic],
fourth at Agrarin [phonetic].
So, everywhere he used to stay,
he had a lovely [inaudible] stock,
and I will show one manuscript,
which is noted in Berlin Library,
decoration that he purchased that
book, written by [inaudible],
printing done by [inaudible] at
the cost of 3000 rupees in 1598.
This is one of the copies again
from [inaudible] on Diwan-e-Saib
and an port of Jahangir and
Shah Jahan period [inaudible].
And it shows that this work is
scribed by a renowned calligrapher,
Shafia, and who was also
officially the [inaudible].
And the seals are also
plated by these people.
This is a renowned work on
the Molin [phonetic] ethics.
It's also interesting that in the
telegram apart from [inaudible].
From the [inaudible]
was always there,
and then the famous [inaudible] that
one person asked for [inaudible],
you learned [inaudible]
ethics from home, he said,
from those who don't know.
So, this is one, and this is the
writings that Merdowyn [phonetic]
by [inaudible], the same
one is from Jahangir
and the Ustrut [phonetic] collection
of the libraries, the seed was put
up and the writing was as
[inaudible], and the signature,
I told my dear friend, Hirad,
on that day that they will make
like the palm of the Punjab, but
that is not the Punjab of the palm.
The word is forget
[phonetic], out of humble
and humility they will
just mention then
to forget there is alone
means this [inaudible],
the person who does
not know anything.
And it says, again, from
Rampur Raza, Diwan-e-Haliz,
which is recently reproduced
and published and presented
to many [inaudible]
across central Asia
when our Prime Minister had visited.
This is the [inaudible] of a
manuscript of Kalileh-Wa-Dimnah,
scribed by an unknown scribe, so
[inaudible] and that [inaudible]
and it is from the
early 16th century
and [inaudible] there are two
manuscripts from this calligrapher.
One is Florence and
the other is this one.
A little bit hard, well, I was able
to publish the whole
manuscript last year with a sort
of Indian cultural concept and
this is our front page of that one,
and it was released by our Honorable
Prime Minister last year in Iran,
and copies were distributed
among all the scholars free
of cost at that time.
It has about 120 illustrations
by Raza [phonetic],
and one can also see in these
printings, which is gestured
in this one, in majority of the
illustrated manuscripts, scribed
and printed in Iran,
there's one discrimination.
They're not filled the page square.
They mix some scale type so that
it is not the full square in that,
while the same is not
followed in India and either
in regional or the imperial ones.
This, again, the manuscript
from [inaudible] are [inaudible]
a story from [inaudible].
It's an 18th century
manuscript, and see the colors,
and I will request
it all to compare it
with our manuscript of
Shada Ama [phonetic].
He has in his collection, a
Library of Congress collection,
and the same high colors are
used and especially the red one
and the green one, and these
can be made a comparative study
of these illustrations, basically.
This is an opening
photo of the same.
This is again, as I said, there
are many private collections.
This is a manuscript from
Hong Kong in [inaudible].
They have about 270
manuscripts of various regions
in the non-religious sects,
and I hope [inaudible] will be
and the [inaudible] will be
successful as I persuaded them
to allow the digitization
of these manuscripts.
This is our last [inaudible]
of the same.
Then, as I said, people which
was one of the mirror objects
to create manuscripts was from the
Kashmiri, in fact, and it was used
by many especially like scribe
moment of [inaudible] Kashmiri,
or [inaudible], who was
also one of the transcribers
and inscription writers
in [inaudible], basically.
And we had a detail in minister sell
above the paper; these are coming
from where, and you know
today, in many cities,
you will have a [inaudible]
or [inaudible] walla.
Our colors was ours.
Even though today there may be
a [inaudible] and other things
but still not the same nomenclature.
Like the Ahmedabadi paper
was very glossy and stout,
had a few varieties
like Bahadur Khani.
Shabib Khani, well
actually, what used to happen
when [inaudible] the Emperor used to
reach in that particular locality.
They will produce the
paper particularly
and name that paper to him.
I remember it isn't [inaudible]
when through then Iran
[inaudible] second,
at least [inaudible] first time,
and there's a very good
market about paper production.
They named after him this one.
Then, as I mentioned, in the
case of the Rahim Khan-e-Khanan,
all the skilled people from gildis
to warraq [phontic] or [inaudible],
all the scribe, all the printer,
all the [inaudible], all were always
in the libraries, and even for
of a lack of the paper maker,
their specialty works which they
had to give before the work start.
In many cases, you will find
that matter is written first
and the space is left for the
printing, or the vice versa too.
In the [inaudible] manuscripts,
which were in the royal libraries,
there were royal signets,
and many were reproduced
with a highly American form.
This is one of the seal with
a board water [phonetic]
from early 18th century.
It is a work of Miratul
Istelah of Anjman [inaudible]
which I edited and
published recently.
It was again published
by an Iranian publisher,
a copy which I gave yesterday,
a gift to Professor Shallows.
This seal starts from the top,
I don't know whether you can see
my finger or not, and that one,
middle one starts through the side
[inaudible] that is [inaudible].
And in the middle one, the name
of the then King [inaudible]
and that first one starts with
his following the cycle goes
on as a generalitical table.
But then, other regional areas
were moguls were not the Emperors
dictated [inaudible] kind of a seal.
If the kingdom is from the
Semites, they'll write name
of the [inaudible] and
on the corners name
of the qualified [inaudible],
the first [inaudible].
Or they will just put the flowers
or like [inaudible] in that
to illuminate that with
especially the red color
and especially of the documents.
The majority of the
seals, like this one,
as I mentioned the fly leaves
are important in they tell us
about the programs and
the prices and all this,
and the mention about this one.
And they'll also mention the
place, like this is on the property
if you can read, it is [inaudible].
And also, remember, we have some
similar words for different cities,
like [inaudible] was for Baka.
[inaudible] also, and
we have presented
but it hasn't also the
short form of [inaudible].
You'll find in some scripts.
This is, in fact, from
[inaudible] manuscript,
and a very informative one.
So, this is from Solagan
and this is [inaudible]
of early mid-18th century, and
it gives a complete detail how
to function used to have meetings
in the society in the ending times.
Yeah, these are the fly leafs,
which gives ample information
about every manuscript.
You can see on the left side,
this is a note by Jahanir;
middle one is by Shan
Jahan, and the middle one is
by Abdur Rahim Khan-e-Khanan,
who procured this manuscript
in 1998 [inaudible] after he got
[inaudible] with [inaudible],
and many of these manuscripts
he procured there.
Even he sent the delegation to go
out to purchase certain manuscripts
which are brought by
Portuguese from Iran.
So, this kind of that will tell us
how Persian manuscripts were bought,
sources of trading also.
And this is again from
the Solagan one.
Yeah. This is a very
dear manuscript.
I hope [inaudible] and surprised.
This is Nadir Shah siting on an
elephant, a manuscript from 1780s,
and in state archives Allahabad.
I found it, really, it
was surprising for me too.
And none of Iranians have
this kind of illustration
of another [inaudible], and it is
another manuscript not published
yet, and it is first I mentioned
in this illustration also.
This is one of the manuscripts which
contributes some claims of scholars
like Abani [phonetic], writer of
many books on the calligraphers.
This method of Bostan National
Museum, Bali, scribed in 1504
to 1508, and the writing is
by Abdur Rahim Khan-e-Khanan,
and it tells us the seal is by
Niasiruddin of Malwa [inaudible],
who ruled between 1500
to 1510 early.
The manuscript is in [inaudible]
script, and it's surprising
that scribe, this [inaudible] is
not mentioned in any anthology
of the biographies of that
scribes, and it's from that period,
and the manuscripts in
[inaudible] as you can see.
And there's a premodel
[phonetic] manuscript.
It has about 80 illustrations,
even one illustration
from [inaudible] Temple, which is a
[inaudible] travel of [inaudible],
but it's a beautiful
illustration in this one.
Apart from that, there are
many other illustrations
which show each story of Bostan
and but the million patterns
of this work is the work was scribed
in premodel period in the study.
The work [inaudible]
with the [inaudible].
Then it went to the
Museum [inaudible]
and [inaudible] during
the seed of [inaudible],
gifted to Abdur Rahim
Khan-e-Khanan, and he made a note
on this manuscript in the bottom.
This is the writing of
Abdur Rahim Khan-e-Khanan.
I published this in
a separate article
in a volume recently
published by Arkhan Foundation
on Abdur Rahim Khan-e-Khanan,
and this [inaudible]
that in they are manuscripts of
Iran that Shumsa [phonetic] is used
as the seal of the library.
In India, it became a fashion
that Shumsa, the opening sum
of that book, showing the light is
used as the seal of the library.
This is a seal.
If you can't read it,
in the middle one,
it is an item by [inaudible] now
should have been [inaudible] a place
of, places of scribe
is Malu [phonetic].
In Malwa, which the capital at that
time of this [inaudible] in fact.
So, this is, this shows that
a variety of the manuscripts
in them collection
tells us the history
of the various scripts started
[inaudible] there in fact.
Yeah, this is a manuscript not
from Indian collection but Berlin,
but I brought it here
just for the information.
The whole writing from left to right
is by Abdur Rahim Khan-e-Khanan,
and he tell us how this, and I've
given the translation over here,
that how this was brought in
[inaudible] from [inaudible]
in three instalments, and he had
to send about 2000 to 3000 rupees
to the people who are having
it in the fragments, in fact,
and 1 percent where some lives.
He thought that Abdur Rahim
Khan-e-Khanan will give him more
money, so he started moving
from and what was on himself.
But on the way, the [inaudible]
looked at this all things,
and those things also, then it
became in the hands of [inaudible],
and they also sold
it to someone else.
Then I came to tell him we were sent
to procure those, and at the end,
Abdur Rahim Khan-e-Khanan tells
us that the work described was
for [inaudible] and
[inaudible] and it took 12 years
for the preservation and the
conservation by the guilders
and the printers and the
scribes of the same one.
Then, a writing by Shah
Jahan and a ownership seal
by Auragzeb [phonetic] tells us the
manuscript has been in development,
but the middle seal again tells us
that this was a piece to [inaudible]
in the collection of Abdur
Rahim Khan-e-Khan to let,
but now it is in the
Library of Berlin.
And it also gives the detail
because there was a [inaudible];
again Abdur Rahim Khan-e-Khanan,
and he said this is the work
which give this mission
and due to my, with this,
I was saved by becoming a victim, as
a conspiracy was hatched against me.
So, political notes are
also in the fly leafs notes
by these nobles of the noble period.
Again, the seal of the
preservation of conservation,
the masters of [inaudible] National
Museum and really the [inaudible]
and the Noble [inaudible]
mentioned that it became
in a very dilapidated condition,
and it took us about 12 years
to put it back to the level
of [inaudible] and coloration,
and you can see what [inaudible]
did assure the collection
of the library, and about 13
collection notes are there,
which are mainly from the
[inaudible] superior in fact.
Again, a variety of seals,
this is in collection history,
how people were interested in
knowing the various things.
These collection notes tell us
how the books were collection
between then.
I remember there is a book, a
manuscript and volume I see,
be at our library, and the fly
leaf says, this book is mine.
It'll be authenticated by the 12
persons giving their [inaudible].
No one shall steal it.
If he or even steal it, he will
not get place even in [inaudible].
And yeah, but if he
ask to borrow it,
he must bring signature
of two people.
So, that when repairs
it, it has been.
Yeah, it should return to me because
this is our only work of Briston
in the whole that region.
This is the posity [phonetic]
of the paper, basically,
which increase the [inaudible].
And I got ample collection, which
gives a various description.
Also, remember that they mention
that prices of the manuscripts also
and which of the currency they paid.
If it is paid in [inaudible] or
home, only the coin of [inaudible],
even the [inaudible], [inaudible]
first coined in [inaudible].
Then went to Perjorgia, even
that time of the [inaudible]
to [inaudible] but
it came into fashion
in [inaudible] other
[inaudible] period,
and it remained until 17th century.
They mentioned that this work is
purchased at the cost of this one.
Here, the numbers were written
in [inaudible] and the words also
so that no one can make
any changes in that.
This [inaudible] mascot and as I
mentioned some prior collection
of Bhandarkar Institute.
I could not take a very
good picture out of it.
On that day, I hadn't my camera.
I took it from some other one,
but the whole [inaudible]
were eliminated,
and it's why from a very
unknown part, Mobid Kashmiri,
who came to [inaudible] from
Kashmiri lived 17th century.
And in [inaudible] he
has given a variety
of that political collections,
especially on the birth of a child,
you got, it's [inaudible]
of the triplets
in many cases, and he composes that.
Yeah, and I was mentioning
in my preamble
that manuscripts were not
only scribed or illuminated
or illustrated in the
Imperial or regional course.
It's for out of that society also.
This is one of the manuscripts
in my own [inaudible]
library about the society.
It's a body of work
whom our older works.
I hope one lady from
Pakistan, I was introduced.
She might be looking
on them exactly.
And no one tries even to teach
that compilations here [inaudible].
But today, students of the
history are working on it
because the language is used.
It is called unethical,
abusive, that kind of the,
but the society depiction
is also there.
But for the society,
both are using that kind
of the language also sometimes.
And here, it [inaudible] the school
and the marissa [phonetic]
how the students
and the teacher are
sitting in that one.
And second one is more interesting.
Mother-in-law took
her daughter-in-law,
who is not becoming pregnant, to
this hakim, exactly what hakim was,
and the astrologer also,
and she took to him
to get some kind of
advice from that.
So, these manuscripts show
us society, the period,
and also the occupational detail.
The colors which were used in
that, again, see [inaudible]
that green color is used.
That dark red color is used.
Manuscripts is [inaudible]
like that.
Then, 18th century was a
period of transition also.
When ministers were created
for the new [inaudible],
that is the pictures
of the European forces.
Maps were taken and the pictures
are; then, European techniques,
and this is one of the
manuscripts, Chahar Gulshan,
which I published in 2011.
It has maps from Decan
[phonetic] up to [inaudible].
There are three other
details, and as for that,
some scholars of geography and the
cartography, this is a first work
on European cartographical
styles and effect.
Then, again, this is from
[inaudible], with a manuscript
in National Museum Delhi.
Now, there are some who wrote
the work, transcribed the work,
and printed the work; he's a
single person, Mullah [inaudible].
He has beautifully illustrated
this manuscript, he has given all
with idea of the subjects in
this one, from the good life
to the one, to the hunting also.
Hunting only with the ladies.
And here, the French Ambassador
is being received in the Fort
of the Goolgooda [phonetic],
and the whole city map is
there, in fact, if you can see.
And the dresses of, one
dress I was being shown
by [inaudible] on that day.
Now, I'm showing you this
one, and this show, this one.
This is the [inaudible] manuscript,
which tell us about the market
of Mathura and Ojen [phonetic].
People are selling.
You can eat it.
[Inaudible] fed to cannibals, what
[inaudible] fed to kind of sell off
that portion or dealing in the
paper, and this is the one when,
again, tradition that
loud cry was given.
The rights of the collection or
the text is by Shahalam in 1751,
and from the time when
the history changes,
and there's the post
decline, a resulting effect.
This is the works of another
text on the music one, as I said,
when I give a subject, and
four other Vernaculo words.
You can see that script is Persian,
but the words are not the Persian
language, and this is a thing
which has to be done, and we
usually call it a Persian,
but not the Persian words.
Persian was dethroned in 1837
by [inaudible] but Persian
and India continued until 1940s.
This is one of the sample I'm giving
and from a non-Muslim ruling class
from [inaudible], which shows that
until 1911, even I have a document
from 1943 that they are
showing that the communications
between the various
chieftans was in Persian.
You can see the gold
seals also on this one.
This is one of a manuscript which
tells us a word is used on many
of the manuscripts when
in location, Yak bi kaj.
It kind of a pub, which was
missing from by various scholar
that it is a kind of ant as being
used by antidote for the others;
but now it is a hub one can see and
[inaudible] also or the dictionary
of the medicine plants, published
in three volumes from Tehran.
This is a hub, and it is
used on many manuscripts
with a notation, God
may save this book.
So, with this, I conclude
this brief detail
on various collections
of Persian manuscripts.
Apart from it, I even mentioned
that it is not only Persian
manuscripts in India.
We have in Islamic scripts
manuscripts in Turkish.
We recently published
from [inaudible] Library Rampur
collection and the catalogue
of the Turkish manuscripts.
We have manuscripts in
African, a lot, a lot,
that I gave them [inaudible] have
these [inaudible], which are,
have been put up and the divisions
have been published in India.
Likewise in [inaudible] also.
[Inaudible] also.
[Inaudible] in Islamic script also.
Kashmiri in Islamic script also.
These are in abundance in India,
but there is a [inaudible] decrees
in the script knowing
people of this huge campus,
and we are facing the problem as
you are also facing about this one,
and especially about the
documents which are in huge number,
really huge number, but we need
students, who should come forward.
We will provide all the
detail and the help to them.
Unfortunately, the Indian
government announced
that whoever will do
period in Persian
from outside the [inaudible] will
not recognized by the Ministry,
so people are stopped
coming from there.
They are doing Buddhist studies.
They are doing something else.
Bring, there are accepting
the Persian sources,
but they cannot get the deal in
Persian studies, unfortunately.
But this, this is not a complaint.
This is their own policy;
we cannot enforce it.
Thanks.
[ Audience Applause ]
>> Hirad Dinavari:
Thank you very much.
That was a wonderful talk.
That was fantastic.
Thank you, but before you
leave, in the beginning,
you gave some statistics, and
you used the Indie word "luck,"
Luck is exactly how many
thousands for folks we don't see?
>> Chander Shekhar:
Hundred thousand.
>> Hirad Dinavari: So, if you
were to, Hackmein [inaudible],
if you were to give some sort of
an estimate, how many hundreds
of thousands of books would you say?
>> Chander Shekhar:
Half million, I said.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Of
Persian manuscripts?
>> Chander Shekhar: Yes.
>> Hirad Dinavari: And
this is not even --
>> Chander Shekhar: And they're four
times more than the document forms.
If you see, and if you
have time, I can show you
about 1000 documents right here.
>> Hirad Dinavari: I understand.
>> Chander Shekhar: Because I've
collected in this trail of 40 years.
Wherever I have been
in various collections,
I tried to get a picture
for my own knowledge.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Right.
Now, this is manuscripts.
Lithographs and early imprints,
how much would you say?
That's the other category.
>> Chander Shekhar: I have
published a book on that.
Novel just shows 1896
list and 2000, right.
Because printing press had come
in India in 16th century, 1582,
brought by the Portuguese,
and then it was shifted
because there was infighting between
various missionaries [inaudible]
because it was brought
by the [inaudible].
Recently, I talked and
I studied [inaudible].
That was something [inaudible]
get written by [inaudible].
Give a picture of the Imperial
a musician to [inaudible],
and that's what its claim.
The book was presented to
Jung [inaudible] himself,
but we don't find any
comment by Jung [inaudible],
even in [inaudible]
to Jung [inaudible].
But from that time, this
printing press has come,
majority of the books were used
also for the missionary purpose.
In that 18th century, when this
[inaudible] Collier established
in Calcutta, majority of the books
were published for that [inaudible]
for that eastern their
company officers.
And from then, not only
the non-illustrated,
illustrated ones also, and even
I think in Library of Congress
and there's some other place else,
where you have highly illustrated
letter printing ones also.
I remember, [inaudible] only it was
by [inaudible] has been prepared.
It's text and published
from Calcutta,
but later on another
manuscript from Puna was prepared
by the Russian Society of them,
and they also edit about 10
to 12 folios prior to the
text about their faith,
about all those [inaudible]
of Puna in that manuscript.
So, they published it.
It really work illustration.
So, little one was adopted because
it can reproduce the handwritten one
in the same form from
first it was in the stones.
We have still got stones used by
[inaudible] in one collection.
And little [inaudible] until 1996,
all they are doing Arabic
newspapers were published
from that little technology
in India.
My father let, they went to Seoul
who brought me this
[inaudible] Persian studies
by the older [inaudible] who
worked with [inaudible] long way
from the [inaudible] and shifted
to [inaudible] and he was always
on the, this [inaudible].
And we had in our own family,
collection from really
early [inaudible].
So, letter was but now letter
become again a manuscript.
Hard to remember.
Masters have not only the
handwritten because in the other way
that letter is also handwritten.
Only thing that we could,
[inaudible] more easily than one
than with the handwritten one.
So, that there's another scope
of work [inaudible] how does letter
interestingly and book writing,
one can write script, but in letter,
it is [inaudible], [inaudible]
and then it has to be printed.
>> Hirad Dinavari: It has
to be printed, exactly.
Again, this can go on
and on [inaudible],
as we say, the story continues.
So, there is many, you know,
angles from which you could look
at the Persian publishing in
India, but I want to open the floor
up for about three questions.
We are already over
our one hour allotment.
[Inaudible], go ahead.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Speak up.
>> Can you give some a mike to her?
>> We don't have one.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Hirad Dinavari: Okay.
Please speak here so
that we can record.
Essentially, the question
was about seals
and the various kinds of seals.
>> Chander Shekhar: They
were the [inaudible]
and they were given
these kind of [inaudible]
of the titles in the various times.
I will send you a copy of my paper
on From the Pain of [inaudible]
or you can also read yourself
[inaudible] who speaks
about three persons
who were [inaudible]
of Abdur Rahim Khan-e-Khanan and
also later on became [inaudible].
These were the titles basically.
This [inaudible] who was
a well-known poet also,
and one works of him that really,
[inaudible] which is really
stand attributed [inaudible]
so after someone else, but
this works is from him.
And there is a manuscript
of this collection
at the Museum New Delhi also.
But basically, these
other titles given
on the various times
[inaudible] is also title.
It is not his name.
>> You referred at the very end
to the fact that studying Persian
in India may not be
acknowledged in mainland Iran
because they basically think of
it as a kind of an offshoot there.
But outside Iran, there is a lot
of interest in the Persian network.
All these different constellations
or cultures which are very vibrant,
and they have Persian in there
and so that was not surprising
because I'm sure you
know and all that.
Is there a way that
there could be, you know,
kind of why would it be
illegitimized by one country?
There should be ways
of coming together
to make this a legitimate study of
Persians, based on what is available
to you and the scholars that are
there in India, in Central Asia.
So, do you see anything like
that happening in India?
>> Chander Shekhar:
We have [inaudible] Committee
union catalogue not only
of the Indian collection like
Dr. Mosavi [phonetic] did it
for the Pakistan's manuscript,
or recently like [inaudible]
published a collection
of all Persian prints [inaudible].
Problem is that scholars, even
if they want to do the work,
the holders do not allow that.
This is the way it's going on
amongst master [inaudible] in Delhi
and some other parts also,
especially the private holders.
They do not want to part with their
things, even they sometimes resist
that they should not
touch the manuscripts.
It is just a feeling
of the possessiveness.
They don't know everything
has a life.
It is a human being of the
manuscripts, but it is a feeling,
and this is a major hurdle
in creating this kind
of a union catalogue, basically.
Many times we see, like I have shown
you this [inaudible] manuscript,
and when I saw this first time,
[inaudible] a letter to [inaudible]
and it has mentioned
about this manuscript,
but I don't know how he missed
this point in this manuscript,
and he didn't read
the fly leaf note.
He just went on the straight
[inaudible] because, as I said,
fly leaf marks are very
much important about these.
But there should be more to give
and make a comprehensive report
on variety of this work [inaudible].
But it's not a simple
thing, in fact.
You can make a project
but implement.
Some of the things is
a little bit difficult.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Last question.
[inaudible]
>> Chander Shekhar: Yeah, please.
>> Right. First of
all, thank you so much.
I've learned so much
from your presentation,
and I heard [inaudible].
Again, I'm not [inaudible]
expert and so I wanted to ask you
if someone like me, a lay person,
were looking at a Persian manuscript
in India, what would you say
would be the major characteristic
that would differentiate it
from a manuscript [inaudible]
in Iran, for example, in Persia?
What would be the five or six things
that I should be looking at and say,
okay, this is a manuscript
made in India?
>> Chander Shekhar:
Very good question.
I will need some time, I
hope you will give that.
There were two types of the scribes,
one who had the mother tongue
language, means the Iranians,
of the Persians because of the
Personite world who arrived
in India, and the other other
one, who acquired this language,
especially the comers
of the non-Muslims,
who acquired this language
for various reasons,
not only for their job seeking
burlesque also [inaudible].
One can make a very good distinction
between these two groups.
The first group would write
the manuscript in the form
which is prevalent in
their, back in their country
and more [inaudible] one.
The second group, in
spite of the fact
that they were the best
calligraphers also.
They were not any, many of them
like Charlie von Bremer [phonetic]
who you can [inaudible]
industry has worked.
He was one of the best
calligraphers.
They learned calligraphy
for two reasons.
All of world edits weren't
written by the best calligraphers,
and one was writing, a
single foreman also was
like a privilege for him.
So, they tried to reach
to that stage [inaudible].
These people when scribing
the manuscript,
especially on some [inaudible] they
will create the spellings especially
closer to the natural
position of the word.
While a non-Iranian was a
non-Indian scribe will try
to scribe the word as he has heard.
The reason is it is just the
hearing one and the best example
of this hearing and writing use
dictionary Hopson and Jobson.
I hope every one of you know that.
No? Hopson and Jobson is a
dictionary and it in 1896 compiled
on the basis of all the
messages he collected
from various bishop s[phonetic]
from east he shared with India.
And in the hearing one, he got, many
words he got, which were misspelled
or which are mispronounced
but it is arguing, well,
the two words which he got from Bali
that were lost, Hopson and Jobson,
and the detail was that
in a particular month,
we are hitting two
words in a possession,
and the detail is there
is a possession
and people are beating their chest
and saying, Hopson and Jobson.
The word is Yahusson
[phonetic] and Yahusson,
but they are hearing
Hopson and Jobson.
In the similar way, describes
whatever they were hearing.
I gave one example yesterday that an
Iranian scholar who wrote an entry
and the word alias was presumed
to be a Persian word, and he read,
wrote, Moman Husein
Kharm [phonetic].
Ilias is for Kharm.
Ilias is an English word.
He thought it was a Persian word.
So, similar such mass
level of editors,
and this is one of the reasons.
To find out our own Indie
word what is a transposition
in Persian manuscripts is
difficult for ourselves.
What was a true position, then
we have to concert the transcript
of the all your books, and
then we try to find out.
This is one of the areas
from which you can find out.
Then, the illustrations,
as I have shown you,
they will try to reproduce
these illustrations of variety
of the people of the lower class
especially in the same attire,
giving the same kind of older
man's, all these things.
Then also the buildings.
This is their reading
of them and [inaudible].
Apart from all this,
somewhere you will find
that signs of their faith also.
Many of the non-Muslims relied
in the beginning, [inaudible]
but many will just like [inaudible].
They look like this [inaudible].
So, this is, they created
their own way.
Like in India, a Muslim will
call a Muslim [inaudible]
but if he's admitting a
non-Muslim, he will say of others.
So, of others?
>> Adapt me.
Adopt.
>> Chander Shekhar: So,
society created certain kind
of [inaudible] themselves, and
in some cases it's difficult
because many Indian
non-Muslim writers,
like in this Mobits [phonetic]
manuscript, it's really difficult
to make out whether this Persian
is combined in any of an Indian.
But you get somewhere
form these things.
[ Audience Applause ]
>> Hirad Dinavari: And
thank you to all again.
Again, thanks.
Thank you everyone for coming,
and thank you to the University
of Maryland, to Asian Division,
John, and everyone, thanks again.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us a www.loc.gov.